aoc then comes in after after joe
biden's
campaign manager and likely deputy
uh chief of staff calls republicans a
bunch of efforts
aoc comes in to double down on that but
also in classic aoc fashion
to make it all about her so
marco rubio came out he said biden talks
about unity and healing but you want to
know what they really think read how the
person he wants
as the next white house deputy chief of
staff called republicans in congress a
bunch of efforts
aoc responds marco rubio
you stood by in total silence when your
gop colleague
called a congresswoman an effing b on
the capitol steps in front of press
apparently some congressman insulted aoc
he denied it
and she's a liar so i don't believe her
maybe he did maybe he didn't but i
certainly don't take her at a word
you weren't big enough to speak then and
you don't get to sob now by the way that
is the right word for those who fleece
and scam working families
you got to give the gal credit she makes
every single thing about
her obama was very good at this i hope
that doesn't mean aoc is going to become
president
obama comes he graduates from law school
he's done nothing in his entire life
he's
accomplished nothing in the professional
world in the political world he's just
all he's really done is going through
school
and he writes a book about his absolute
favorite subject
himself then he writes another book
do you know what that book is about give
you a hint it's his favorite subject
himself then he's president you know he
leaves the presidency
and he writes he's now written two books
about himself he then gets a book deal
and he writes a 750-page book
about do you know can you guess
himself all the things he all the
details he left out of the first
600 pages about himself he was able to
fit in to the next 750 pages
that's what aoc does aoc who is
really bad for the country she is a
stain
on american public life she's like a a
festering wound on american public life
ripping up
uh real issues that america's had
also ripping up completely imaginary
issues that america's had everything is
sort of contemptuous of the country
but she's she's not the only person who
does this
the reason she does it is because it
gives her a lot of attention and there
are some republicans who've done that
too
but you know narcissism is a
occupational hazard of politics
aoc does it in particular and the way
she does it is focus on all these
grievances everything is about how she
has been wronged
this is a what 30 year old bartender
with absolutely no qualification to be
in congress
other than her age and she gets this
great cushy job
and a significant amount of influence
and she's still complaining imagine that
imagine still complaining about that
but it's always about grievance and so
for instance if if biden does become
president
he's now going to appoint a native
american cabinet secretary
representative debbie holland to lead
the department of the interior
okay that's fine i don't know anything
about deb holland maybe she's fine
probably she's not if she's gonna be a
biden pick
but that's fine they're not talking
about her qualifications to lead this
department they're not talking about
her experience to lead this department
they're talking about how she's
native american and how this is historic
because you know we've never had native
americans in the government or anything
except that we've actually already had
not just a native american cabinet
secretary
we've had a native american vice
president and we had him as vice
president
91 years ago the 31st vice president of
the united states
1929-1933
first person of color to use the popular
phrase and first native american
to be vice president charles curtis
under herbert hoover was a republican
by the way it's not like he was 132nd
native american or something
the guy had membership in a native
american nation
the guy looked extremely native american
he did it
if you're interested in that sort of
historic breakthrough he did it he was
the guy who did it completely written
out of history
because the left controls the history
books
and so you're not going to hear about
that guy maybe occasionally on some
conservative
talk show or in a conservative book
you'll hear a mention of it you won't
hear it anywhere else
they did this with pete butterjudge they
just pete butterjudge is going to be the
head of the department of transportation
why
i don't does pete buddha judge know
anything about transportation no
probably not
doesn't matter it's historic pete
butterjudge according to the media he's
the first
openly gay cabinet secretary except he's
not we just had the first openly gay
cabinet secretary his name was rick
grinnell under donald trump
that happened like five minutes ago it's
been completely written out already
that that is a conspiracy not
necessarily a conscious one it's sort of
reflexive i think for the left
that they have their narrative and
they're sticking to it
whether reality backs it up or not the
media
certainly aren't going to correct them
you want to see the kind of hard-hitting
journalism we have
so you know the washington post has been
trying to overthrow the 2016 election
since before it
occurred well now that they think
biden's got it certainly he's in
it's done deal here's the kind of
hard-hitting journalism you can expect
from the washington post pete but a
judge is right
airports are romantic
that's the headline that's i'm not
i'm not going to read this article i see
no reason to read this article it is i
did once get pretty romantic with my tsa
agent going up the right leg it was at
least i felt it was romantic i don't
know if if he felt that way as well
uh historic it was an historic uh
airport security line
uh you're not going to get any kind of
uh serious journalism here okay and
you're not going to get it on big tech
either
kareem abdul-jabbar you know karim he
was the basketball star
and then he was an airplane which is my
that's really where i enjoyed his his
work
kareem abdul-jabbar is now saying that
big tech should censor conservatives
and even people who aren't woke just
kind of run-of-the-mill liberals
he says they need to do it because the
conservatives are tweeting
irrational and harmful opinions to
millions
and what's funny his reasoning here is
many americans imbue stars with
political and social intelligence they
just don't have
it doesn't help to be surrounded by
flawing people whose job it is to agree
with everything you say
and you know it's irresponsible and then
they've got to be
censored says kareem abdul-jabbar
a basketball player a very famous
basketball player
and guy who was in some movies and
specifically he was saying that jon
voight should be kicked off
big tech and james woods should as well
two of the only outspoken conservatives
in all of hollywood
those guys are going to come after you
too
it is not conspiracy theory thinking
to say that we need to be skeptical of
these established institutions the
government institutions
and even the institutions outside of the
government
it's the only conspiracy theory is that
those institutions are not political
that that isn't truly a crazy conspiracy
theory
there is a i guess you could use the
word conspiracy it's not really a
conspiracy it's just
an establishment it's an established
standard
across all of these different sectors
all of which
are hell-bent on shutting up
conservatives
making sure we don't have a voice you're
not going to get that unity and healing
assuming joe biden gets it january 20th
you are going to get a vindictive
response revenge
and if conservatives don't prepare for
that now and if we're not prepared to
fight on every
front of that not just the governmental
front but also
in commercial life also in educational
life
also in technology if you're not
prepared to fight on all those fronts
we don't stand a chance